tribalism
hatred
[Music]
violence
politics in America and Britain are now
hyperpolarized online and on streets
there's much more heat than mines
and race and the environment
[Applause]
[Music]
to gender and abortion
important issues are making us more
divided
this kind of polarized politics has a
name
a culture War the culture culture
culture wars the cultural Wars are toxic
so what's fueling today's culture wars
culture wars are in general good for
political Elites the constant pressure
of this manufactured outrage
are we as divided as we seem we see a
lot of non-debate from the other side
and how worried should we be about the
future of liberal democracy every time
you hear a claim you believe it a little
more
foreign
[Music]
it's the start of Labor Day weekend in
America
with the mid-time elections just over
two months away thanks Tom Jones
American tanks
a Democratic candidate for the house is
out campaigning
herb Jones rough office remember
Congress as Republicans what do they
stand for and they really can't tell you
the previous president I have zero
respect for him he's a coward and a
crook
even with a holiday in Prospect there's
no escaping the better divide between
America's two main political parties
we have Democrats now who are far
extreme left who are pushing an agenda
this is completely Un-American and here
in Virginia one factor in flaming the
political debate is claims over teaching
in schools of something called critical
race Theory or CRT the idea that racial
bias is baked into American society I am
concerned about critical race Theory
being taught in our Public Schools
nobody wants to be told that they're an
oppressor and that they're they should
pay for what they did critical race
theory is a red herring what happened
last year is you had Republicans who
manipulated this whole critical race
Theory up and they scare people they use
it to scare folks
the route in Virginia over critical race
Theory exploded here
[Applause]
in June 2021 angry parents stormed this
school board meeting in Loudoun County
you need to be arrested
complaining that their children were
being brainwashed and taught to believe
that white Americans are racist
oppressors
you are not teaching my children that
they are racist just because they're
white the problem I have is that my son
was being taught propaganda they alleged
this teaching was based on an academic
idea from the 1970s called critical race
Theory it's a critical race theory has
its roots in cultural Marxism it should
have no place in our schools
[Music]
critical race Theory basically asked a
question
why is it that individual racism is
improving over time and yet racist
outcomes persist
critical race theorists look at if we
don't change the structures and the
institutions and the policies that were
built by races then racism will never
improve arguments in Virginia about
teaching critical race Theory helped
catapult a once obscure academic debate
we've woken up millions of parents to
the dangers of critical race Theory into
a red-hot national fight
Republican politicians across the
country started campaigning strongly
against it and approved rules Banning
teaching CRT in 17 States another book
that is on the summer reading for third
through fifth grade it asks the question
can we send white people back to Europe
dividing kids based on race trying to
say summer oppressors and some are
oppressed those things are poison
thank you
the truth about what CRT really is
quickly got lost
and so did something else
although some schools do focus on racism
in America critical race theory in its
traditional academic form has never been
widely taught to American children
so what's really going on
there is misunderstanding on all sides
of this
stupid critical race Theory there isn't
enough empathy from progressives for
understanding how uncomfortable and how
worrisome conversations about race are
to some Families my youngest looks very
white so they would look at her and say
you are an oppressor and I don't see how
it's not gonna pass Society to move
further apart
on the other side
there is the conservative Distortion and
the conservative Distortion turns
critical race Theory into so many things
school choice week in America and a lot
of folks across the country are
demanding change to our broken education
system we have this group of
conservative activists who are using the
anti-crt frenzy to move forward a
different political agenda
part of that political agenda involves
whipping up critical race Theory into
the latest front in America's so-called
culture wars
tapping into a fundamental conflict
about America's future
and what it means to be an American
why don't Republicans want kids to know
how to not be racist
and deepening the political divide
between Republicans and Democrats
eighty percent of Republicans believe
that America is in danger of losing its
culture and identity
compared with just 33 percent of
Democrats
the rage over CRT is a textbook example
of how good politicians have become at
exploiting these grievances around
identity
Republican politicians in particular
to this day many Americans believe that
we are the best country
and starts to challenge that and that
can be very threatening particularly if
your identity as an American is a strong
part of who you are stoking the cultures
has become a highly effective political
strategy using emotions and fear to
Trump facts and reason we have evidence
that shows every time you hear a claim
you believe it a little more even if
it's a crazy claim and even if it's
something at Baseline you didn't believe
it all just hearing it makes it more
believable
these kinds of culture worth are in
general good for political Elites it
helps mobilize people that helps pull
people in
and it's not just politicians who profit
from fueling the Grievances of the
culture wars
the media do too
actresses went from being a beloved
childhood author to worse than Hitler in
just a matter of days on eBay you are
allowed to shop for copies of mineconf
you can buy all the racist filth you
want if it's about white fragility
between 2016 and 2020 Fox News Prime
Time viewership increased from just
under 1.9 million to just under 3.1
million Donald Trump and the mega
Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic and
sections of the liberal media have also
profited
by the end of Donald Trump's term as
president
subscriptions to the New York Times had
increased from 3 million to 7.5 million
so how did we arrive at this kind of
divisive politics
the term culture wars goes back to 19th
century Prussia
it was first popularized in America as a
struggle between conservative and
Progressive World Views in the
post-civil rights era
and observers agree that 2016 was a
turning point
not only with the election of Donald
Trump but also Britain's vote to leave
the European Union
political beliefs became more closely
intertwined with identities
people view themselves through these
issues like what you stand for is who
you are the political is personal
so it would be quite usual in the years
after brexit to be in a in a in a dating
app like Tinder and you would see people
saying oh if you voted for brexit swipe
left or today you see people say if
you're vaccinated swipe left I don't
want anything to do with you
this shift is also reflected in the
Loyalty of American voters towards their
political parties
that loyalty has increased over the last
four decades but the rise since 2016 is
particularly Sharp
in the run-up to the last presidential
election 89 of Donald Trump supporters
believed a victory for Joe Biden would
cause lasting harm
and 90 percent of Biden supporters felt
the same about a trump win
in this kind of personalized politics
hatred of your opponent fuels a desire
to defeat them at all costs the left has
decided to try to destroy our culture
you have many many Republicans
who are kind of giving up on democracy
and want to move us into an
authoritarian form of society
sociologists call this effective
polarization
very easy to see the other side is
completely alien from you
you end up with the academics call Mega
identities
that's a zero-sum gain that the other
group has to lose in order for you to
win that becomes really difficult to
move societies forward together the root
of the problem is that fewer and fewer
people think that they have the capacity
to understand the world with their own
judgment
these big narratives of the of socialism
of capitalism had the positive view
about the future
the idea was follow us and we will bring
you to a society of plenty of justice of
meritocracy
so as these big ideologies wither away
now it's more of a defensive battle
they fall in this tribalistic kind of
conflict where they view the world
through the prism of hating the other
group
[Music]
in this era of tribal politics
genuinely complex problems of identity
are feeding into the culture wars and in
Britain this is playing out in the
vigorous debate about transgender rights
let me ask you a question perhaps the
most intractable culture War issue they
are legitimate areas of concern you
can't just call everyone who disagrees
with us
foreign
event in England proud expressions of
transgender identity are on show
police fraternize with pride parade
Leo who campaigns for transgender and
gay rights is joining festivities
but she's also mindful of a backlash
we're almost experiencing a crisis of
visibility there are conspiracy theories
that trans people are taking over
because people feel like they see more
trans people around them like many in
the transgender Community Cleo says
negative media coverage is one reason
the issue of transgender rights has
become so noisy and divisive in Britain
there is a sort of
cyclical relationship between the media
and the political establishment it just
shifts copy it's almost soapy in a very
Grim way
at the heart of this quote unquote
culture War are individuals people who
just want to get on with their lives and
instead they're having to deal with the
constant pressure of this
this manufactured outrage
the media may be a factor but
transgender rights have become a
uniquely toxic and polarizing issue
so what else explains why the opposing
sides feels such animosity
[Applause]
perhaps no other issue speaks more to a
fundamental sense of identity and self
on both sides on one side a transgender
rights activists who insist on an
unqualified legal right to be recognized
as the gender or sex with which they
identify it's a culture war between
those who believe that trans rights are
human rights and those who believe that
they are not human rights or that those
rights should somehow be restricted or
controlled
spend time like it or lump it on the
other side many so-called gender
critical activists say this argument is
disingenuous and point to the fact that
transgender rights are already protected
by law something they're not opposed to
what they oppose is a change in the law
to self-identification
whereby anyone can be legally recognized
as the sex with which they identify
without any medical gatekeeping they say
this would allow any biological man into
any women's space and override hard-won
women's rights
the argument is not about whether there
should be legal protections for Trans
people there should be the argument is
whether we should change these existing
legal protections as soon as a male says
I Feel Like a Woman according to this
idea they should have access to all the
spaces and resources and rights that a
woman has that's the that's the bit I'm
objecting to this is a debate where
convictions are deeply rooted on both
sides it's not like a civil war both of
them are kind of fundamental doctrines
both sides are making kind of strong
principled uh
far-reaching claims and that's why it's
so difficult to reach a compromise an
irresistible Force meeting immovable
object
[Music]
the conversation where many are scared
to voice their opinions for fear of
abuse or even losing their jobs
we sometimes do get blocked
and those who do speak out can be
polarizing figures
if you can look at the person next to
you and you can say women don't have
penises I promise we will win
Kelly J Keen is an outspoken critic of
gender identity ideology and a staunch
defender of women's rights
the reason the debate is
uh contentious and occasionally violent
is because we're fighting the truth
against some quasi-religious dogmatic
new religion and so when you talk about
things that are true against things that
are not the things that aren't true have
to be defended quite violently and so we
see a lot of non-debate from the other
side
yet that other side insists its
opponents are equally dogmatic it's a
culture War at its most intractable
leaving little hope of resolution
no women I mean the old-fashioned ones
you know old-fashioned women oh God you
know the ones with wombs
[__] dinosaurs
Little Wonder it's causing new fractures
across Society
including within liberal groups like
Britain's labor party where the issue
has become a hot potato it's transphobic
to say only women have a cervix well it
is something that shouldn't be said
like many other arguments the
transgender rights debate is being
fueled by something at the heart of all
today's culture wars digital technology
social media amplifies extreme content
creating polarization
there's this great overestimation of how
extreme the views of people on the other
side are and even how extreme the views
of the average person on your side uh
are and this really contributes actually
to polarization is people think
everybody else is really extreme and
then that drives them to be extreme
themselves correct the misperceptions
that are relevant
to the like attitude that you're trying
to move
Professor David Rand has researched the
ways online Echo Chambers reinforce
existing views and prejudices
when you get some new pieces of
information how are you supposed to tell
whether it's true or not we just think
in the context of all the other things
that I know about the world how much
sense does this piece of information
make
[Music]
Professor rand's findings about why
misinformation is shared online may not
be what you'd expect
he ran an experiment
one group of people were shown headlines
and asked if they would share them
a second group was shown the same
headlines and asked if these were
accurate
when it comes to what they would share
there's like they're you know less
likely to share the true ones they're
more likely to share the false ones we
see that when you ask people to judge
whether it's true or not they do pretty
well however the people that you ask
about sharing they're pretty much
indifferent and they're more or less
equally likely to share the true and
false headlines and so this shows that
there's a disconnect between what people
believe and what they actually share he
discovered people share false content
primarily because they are distracted
and his research suggests encouraging
them to think about accuracy can stop
this
we're all existing in this information
ecosystem where we're distracted all the
time
so the idea is you want to get them to
think about accuracy when it matters
platforms are very good at getting
people to pay attention to things they
don't want to pay attention to namely
ads that's their whole business and so
we are proposing is that they should use
some of the attentional muscle they've
developed in the context of ads to help
people pay attention to accuracy
attention deficits
opportunistic politicians
cynical media identity politics
these are some of the forces driving
polarization in today's culture wars
the culture wars are bad news for
democracy pushing citizens into conflict
but are they also bad news in other ways
creating a climate where agreed citizens
push the police to act illiberately
it's battle for democracy democracy
relies on antagonism
Harry Miller lives in the ancient
English County of Lincolnshire
he's a former police officer who found
himself on the wrong side of the law
in 2019 Harry satirized the government's
plan to recognize gender
self-identification in law with coarse
words on Twitter
a single distinct event or occurrence
which disturbs or causes a person
concern it's just
received a complaint about transphobic
tweets
and Harry received a visit from his
former employers
when PC goal said I'm here to check your
thinking
you could have knocked me down with a
feather did you realize that 1984 is a
dystopian novel it's not a police how-to
manual
the police recorded the tweets as
something called a non-crime hate
incident a legal tool designed to
monitor potentially violent people and
even though Harry had not broken any law
he learned the police could keep his
case on file for up to six years he took
the police to court Mr Justice Knowles
that equated it to the gestapo and the
starsy
where the judge ruled that they had
acted unlawfully and interfered with his
right to freedom of expression
hey Anna Anna how's it going
Harry has since discovered that a
hundred and twenty thousand non-crime
hate incidents were recorded between
2014 and 2019. although the particular
circumstances of these cases are not
public knowledge
[Music]
some Fair the culture wars are leading
to a more worrying level of State
overreach in Scotland where politicians
have passed a new law influenced by
identity politics
to every person in the transgender
Community attacked for simply being who
you are then this bill is for you and we
are that voice in 2021 the Scottish
parliament passed the hate crime and
public order act the heat Crane and
public order bill that I brought forward
as cabinet secretary for justice was
essentially extending the same rights
protections that people of color already
have a law to the other protected
characteristics from religion right
through to disability transgender
identity and so on
this law criminalizes offensive speech
towards transgender people including
speech that takes place in private for
example at home
stirring up hatred with speech that is
considered insulting or inflammatory
even if no actual harm results is
punishable by up to seven years in jail
even some of those who campaign actively
for transgender rights are worried this
goes too far
interdemocratic Society
there is no right to not be offended
so criminalizing causing offense is a
threshold too far
much as I oppose hate crime and think
perpetrators should be brought to
Justice
I think we have to be very careful about
criminalizing opinions that people
simply find offensive or disagreeable
open question just how much of a threat
the culture wars posed to British
democracy
what's certain is that American
democracy faces a more serious and
Urgent risk
oh
in America the polarization of the
culture wars is helping to increase
political violence and the risks of
Greater violence in future
disliking people on the other side
that's not really the problem in and of
itself that's a problem in so much as it
leads people to have anti-democratic
attitudes and you know to be willing to
engage in political violence
America Congress by the way we need
somebody that actually represents us
back at the County Fair in Virginia
there's a feeling that American
democracy is flying by the seat of its
pants
I support being a peaceful American but
people turn to violence whenever they
feel that their voice is not heard if we
don't get past this
our country and our future is in
jeopardy
if we don't we're going to lose our
democracy and we're going to lose our
freedoms
fixing this broken politics requires a
fundamental transformation in behaviors
and structures
but in both America and Britain the
polarization of the culture wars make
that feel a long way off
we have to
again the thing which is quite out of
action which is view people as
individuals with free will not view them
as avatars of their identity and this
deterministic beings who do as their
identity asks them to do
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe